who wants to hear more about volumetric
Dada yeah Mao says I love it you love
that much my favorite kind of data I
thought it was so that might be the case
well now that everyone can access the
voxels yeah
and work with them a team at DreamWorks
Animation created an open VDP open VDB
is sorry so funny Margo it's just the
name of thank software I don't know why
get it together hey this is so immature
open open VD is available
open VDP is available as open source
software and provides a powerful tool
set to restrict this you guys 42b and
manipulate the voxels okay it's all
about the voxels
huh
yes there we go the open in open VDB is
important by making it available to
everyone it has become the state of the
art workflow choice for many studios
large and small at DreamWorks Animation
the technology has been used most
recently for How to Train Your Dragon 2
to Ken Musa Peter cuca and Mihai Alden
for the creation of open V DB the
Academy presents a technical achievement
award
thank you I would like to express my
deepest gratitude to DreamWorks
Animation for supporting this project
which I can best describe as a pet
project for the past eight years in
particular I'm grateful to DreamWorks
leadership Jeffrey Katzenberg Lincoln
Walden Jeff wag run Henderson and Andrew
Pierce in addition we want to thank
developers David Hill and Akash Kok and
the relentless support from our effects
department in particular Brett Miller
and Jeff Butz Berg major things also
goes to the numerous companies have
adopted open V DB so mention just a few
side effects especially Jeff wag Edward
lamb doodles of domain double negative
Pixar ILM with a solid angle SpaceX and
many many more
last but not least I want to thank my
family starting with my soul mate and
loving my wife Katrina my amazing son
Anders my loving parents Henin Pella my
cool brother Nils my sweet sister Mehta
and finally our cool a pool guy Greg
thank you
everything can said and I'd like to add
a huge huge thank you to my won-won
wonderful wife Kim and to my family for
their support and encouragement thank
you
I just like to thank my family for the
love and support over the years and like
to dedicate this to my dad and my Uncle
Frank wish you could have been here and
like big thanks to the Academy into our
wonderful and intrepid host